It's really tough to answer that because
it's very hard to trust your impressions
in real time.
I'm
in the conservative world.
Paper was starting to say already see,
uh,
it's all going to work in Iraq and
everybody's gonna thank Bush for this.
I'm skeptical of that.
I think the war in Iraq will look like a
mistake by Bush.
Um,
and that,
uh,
his,
um,
generally his,
his approach and foreign policy to,
you know,
as shoe diplomacy and go with unilateral
force will,
will be seen as having been
counterproductive and having decreased
rather than increased American influence
in the world.
So I would predict he would be seen as
rather unsuccessful president in the
realm of foreign policy.
I'm in the realm of domestic policy,
but in my opinion,
by far the most important thing he's
done is,
is uh,
the no child left behind law,
which has been wildly under covered by
the press.
And that'll take years to sift out.
But basically what he has done is it's a
little bit like Nixon to China because
you know,
that are Republican president did.
This is,
say for the first time we're going to
make the federal government a really
forceful dispositive presence in the
American public school system.
And,
and,
and really this will be seen as the
moment when we western Europeanized
ourselves and went from being a place
that,
that where public education is seen as
completely local function to,
uh,
making it a much more of a national
function.
And,
and that'll play out in all sorts of
interesting ways,
whether good or bad.
I don't know.